it's great to be joined today by Daniel
Abraham who is half of the writing team
James sa Corey on the expanse novels as
well as co-executive producer on the
television program based on those novels
Daniel it's so great to talk to you I'm
a fan of the program and I've since
gotten into to the novels on which the
program is based you know we recently
spoke to Ben Mezrich known for of course
the book bringing down the house
ultimately turned into the movie 21 the
book on which the film the social
network was based and we talked a little
bit about just sort of the process of
what it's like to have something that he
wrote turned into in his case a movie in
your case a television program talk to
us a little bit generally about how that
works in other words you've developed
this universe this this environment and
characters in which these stories are
told and then the process begins for
turning it turning it into a TV show
what's the sort of process by which that
happens well the first thing of course
happens is that we find somebody who's
willing to actually do the work and
produce the money which is the
equivalent of winning several lotteries
in a row so that that's getting blind
lucky is the first part and then you
find out kind of who you're working with
we were very lucky because we wound up
paired with Mark Ferguson Hawk Ostby the
guys who wrote children of men and Iron
Man and Alcon entertainment which is the
the company that bought the rights and
brought us all together and Mark and
Hawk were very kind in that they
insisted on bringing us into the writing
room with them and with the team so at
that point we were all of us in there
together
mark showrunner Narayan Shankar was kind
of presiding over us as we rethought the
whole story that we'd written in a way
that would use the toolset for visual
media and when we actually kind of built
it to not be film about hmm and are
there situations where there there were
just aspects of the the books
that just kind of couldn't be replicated
visually and the story had to be
modified as a result of that absolutely
especially in the first book Leviathan
wakes we have a character who is very
introspective and very much lives in his
own head Miller if you're really just
filmed what Miller did in the first book
you'd have a guy sitting in a room
drinking whiskey for a long time and it
would not be compelling television what
are the issues with co-authoring I mean
I can't even imagine like when you when
you guys sit down to write or I guess do
you sit down together to write our
chapters divvied up are certain like the
somebody do dialog and somebody else
does the the non dialogue parts or how
do you even do that it varies a lot
depending on a quick kind which
individual collaboration you're working
with this is one collaboration that I've
done but I've done I've done others with
other people and they all have different
shapes the way that ty and I work
together ty Frank's the other half of
James sa Corey we outline the whole
project together the whole book and then
outline each individual chapter together
so each of us knows what's going to be
in a given chapter and we also have this
rule about how long a chapter is which
makes it really kind of as a gameplay
thing much easier to do then I'll write
one chapter
Tyler write another chapter we'll swap
each of us will edit what the other guy
did we'll put her in the back of a
master document then when the master
document is done one of us will go all
the way through and make all the changes
he wants to make the other guy laughter
that make all the changes he wants to
make so by the end of the whole process
we can tell you who wrote the first
draft of each chapter but we can't tell
you who at which sentence what types of
disagreements are there are there
disagreements like I don't believe this
character would do this or I don't
believe this character would maybe say
this in this particular way are there
disagreements about the story arc with
the story arc and what the project is
that's something we talked about a lot
at the beginning of this it's really
important when you're doing this kind of
thing to have
very clear idea of what you both think
the job is because you know if I'm if
I'm writing a comic space opera and he's
writing a recipe book it's not going to
work out and there's a lot of
practically seem to die because people
don't start off on the same place so we
had a lot of conversation at the
beginning about how we wanted this to
look so we have we have a measure which
there's a question we can say okay does
this get us closer to what we were
aiming for and you know part of the
point of a collaboration is that it's
never going to be what I would have done
by myself if I've written some dialogue
for a character and ty thinks it's wrong
then he should change it and fix it and
make it so we think that's right and as
long as it's in the error bars for me to
then were fun there have been a couple
of times we had disagreements about how
to do a particular scene and with that
we've always kind of had the the base
rule of whichever version is the most
awesome we should do that
it just is vague but but surprisingly
useful so as far as the the story arc of
the television program I mean I've read
that you you have a sense of what the
total arc will be for what I believe
will ultimately is it nine nine books in
the expand series its nine novels and
then a collection of the short stories
so I've read and correct me if I'm wrong
that from the beginning you had a sense
for the total arc of that not just of
each individual book what is or I guess
when I watch other TV shows I often
wonder did they know you know at the end
of season two what the ultimate
conclusion to this series would be and
typically this applies to series that
are not based on on books or a series of
books
what are those conversations like I mean
when you start season one of the TV show
of the expanse and it's not clear
whether this is going to be popular or
it isn't what's the thought process that
goes into where do we leave season one
at its end the
this is let's swing for the fences you
know it's I would love for this to to
get to the complete Ark of the books and
that's what we're aiming for that's you
know we've had this conversation with
Naren our 4runner and what we're going
to try to do is actually the whole thing
and I might I can't speak to Naren or ty
or what their touch downs are but mine
is Babylon 5 which is a wreck 15 that
119 parts Babylon 5 is to my mind one of
the touchstones
for long arc television it's under
appreciated that way but the things that
happen in season 5 season 4 and season 5
are set up in the pilot episode it was a
tremendous act of faith in the creative
process and in the the support of
television for this kind of storytelling
and you know there were compromises
along the way because life intrudes but
overall I think it was a success and
that's the that's the model
I would like to embrace let's dig in a
little bit to the science I mean there's
just so much science of different types
I mean we're talking about physics
spacefaring technology very very long
list what's the process for
familiarizing yourself enough with both
the vocabulary and the concepts to then
be able to integrate it into the
storyline well it helps if you've been a
geek for 20 years before you start okay
that was kind of the past at the time I
both took Thai doesn't have a degree in
science but he studied astronomy and all
the kind of the bodies in the solar
system and and cosmology just as a
educated layman for a very long time
which was part of why I got involved in
the project I solved the the three-ring
binder with all of his research and it
figured out he already knew a bunch of
this stuff because interested him my
degree is in biology I have a bachelors
in biology specializing in genetics so I
had that to draw from and then
everything I've read since then which
you know I got the degree a long time
ago so I've read a lot in the meantime
do you know do you do you have people
who contact you to scrutinize the
minutiae of the science absolutely um
that's that's just something that
happens that's the price of paying
things I sometimes we get it wrong we
certainly have done some things that we
knew we were skating fast on fairly thin
ice but at least we you know we
acknowledge that and we try to make one
pass through the book right at the end
where we take out all the numbers so it
gets harder to criticize us hmm what's
the the most difficult thing about the
tv-show process and I don't know you
know now that you're co-executive
producers we talked about maybe this
problem tends to go away but one of the
one of the areas that people whose books
have been turned into TV shows or movies
that I hear over and over again it's
difficult is when when there are
elements changed and it's changed in a
way that the writer doesn't like well at
that point you as soon as you've sold
the rights to your story it's no longer
your project in their project and we tie
are a very rare position of being able
to be in there and be part of the the
team and be part of the conversations so
yeah there are there are choices and
here's the thing a lot of times there
are choices that are made that I don't
understand and I think are wrong and I
think are leading us down the wrong path
until I see see the final cut and then I
think oh that's that's why they did that
generally speaking it's a terrible idea
to have the writers in the room yes the
the the tool set that I and that to a
lesser degree I think I brings to the
the room is so steeped in a certain way
of thinking tight a little more fluid
and is thinking that I am it tells it
lends itself to a certain kind of
storytelling so for the last three years
really what I've been doing is getting a
crash course in other kinds of
storytelling and visual storytelling and
watching the things that I know very
well be changed and shaped and
translated into this new medium with
this new toolbox yeah there are there
are a lot of times when I don't
understand exactly what we're doing
until I can see the end result and the
people who were working with we got
lucky we've got a really great team we
got a bunch of people who are doing this
because they like the base material they
like the subject matter and so they want
the spirit of the original property the
books to show up however however changed
it needs to be they want that spirit to
be on the screen when we get there well
the end result is working we've been
talking about the expanse and with half
of the writing team Daniel Abraham great
to talk to you thanks so much it's been
a pleasure